[Music]
after students record-breaking
fundraising for charity it's time to
slime the principal
in today's what's cool at school three
school leaders at southern highlands
preparatory school
found themselves slimed this week
a fun way to celebrate record-breaking
fundraising for
american heart association kids heart
challenge the kids said that we looked
like we were inside a bucket of frosting
the school raised a whopping thousand
dollars smashing previous records
in such a hard time our children and our
families were
more giving than ever and students
earned the right to slime
school leaders to fifty three thousand
one hundred and twelve and they were
more than happy to sign their principles
and myself
[Applause]
the kind-hearted fundraising stood out
locally
nationally and worldwide really reach
out and make a difference
and they were so excited to set a record
we're extremely competitive
so number one in nevada number two in
the world they were excited
number two in the world and number one
in nevada
fifth grader kalyn and her sister mila
were top fundraisers
it kind of makes me feel like like
special i guess because it is very hard
to raise like that much money
and after donating all that dough time
to slime
[Applause]
i think cause i got to dump a bucket on
this marin
headmaster martin working the shampoo
trying to get all that out that was all
because of caitlyn and that full bucket
huh
100 raising this money teaches life
skills
how to live healthier and the importance
of giving whether it's
giving our time giving our financial
resources
giving our support with kids right now
in their mental
well-being it is important because lots
of people go through it and stuff
and i wanted to help make a change
[Applause]
and that's what's cool at school if you
know something that's cool at school
head to eight newsnow dot com click on
cool at school under the community
tab or send us an email cool at school
at eightnewsnow.com
we'll continue to feature positive
school stories even during this unusual
time of distance learning
those kids had a little too much fun
with that i'm going to say how much of
that was like pent up like i've wanted
to slime
mrs miller for about three years now and
now finally is my chance
i know and the shampoo that must have
taken and get that out now